hallo leute wir stellen euch heute 20
sätze mit dem werk gehen vor
die konjugation dazu findet ihr in der
infobox
und wenn euch dieses video gefällt dann
gebt uns einen daumen nach oben
ich gehe die treppe hoch her geht weg
ja geht zur haltestelle sie gehen alle
zur haltestelle
sie geht nach hause
es ist grün die leute gehen über die
straße gehen wir zusammen einkaufen
ok
wir gehen hand in hand
wie geht es dir mir geht es gut
was geht denn bei ihm geht es eben
irgendwie nicht gut
kari was geht ab nichts geht auf
ich bin gestern früher nach hause
gegangen
mir ging es nicht gut
gerne stehen wir morgen ins kino das
geht nicht ich muss morgen arbeiten was
ist mit samstag geht das
das würde gehen wir gehen jetzt nach
hause wohin geht ihr jetzt schreibt uns
in die kommentare wohin ihr heute noch
geht und wenn ihr lust habt noch übungen
machen dann werdet ein patchen von easy
german darüber freuen wir uns sehr
und ihr könnt ihr sie german abonnieren
nämlich bis zur nächsten woche ich gehe
2010 es geht die treppe hoch